I always have enough yeah I just got a
voicemail that there's a problem with
the tax return I filed last week and to
call this number
yes I got a voicemail saying there's a
problem with my tax return and to call
this number
yep
first name is seltzer last name is
kolinsky oh man
that didn't work yeah I'm returning a
phone call that's said to call this
number that there's a problem with my
tax return I filed it like 10 days ago
yes I'm here yes ma'am
first name is seltzer last name kolinsky
and I can spell that for you
yes I'm known by both names I'm known by
both names with REI also there was this
platform and the reason we are trying to
reach you two in five years that they
have a response under your name for the
state invasion right now your name is
under federal investigation any phone
calls from your local police department
no nobody no police have showed up yet
all right so do you want me to provide
or did you want me to transfer you get
to the local
no please not goloka no no i would like
to handle this amicably whether it's you
know whether we do a Seltzer exchange or
anything just I'm known as the Seltzer
King and I don't want any trouble from
the police got it I have a piece of
paper I'm ready for the number
Jenny Harper okay that sounds nice okay
and just so I know who I'm dealing with
are you based in Washington DC or where
is your office sorry where are you
located am i speaking to someone at the
IRS in Washington or where where are you
hello you're in Washington
okay very good of course of course
okay and when would I be getting
arrested do you know information egg and
according to this egg you have receive
all the right to gather information
first [ __ ] arrest or facing any kind
of legal consequence and this is also
much of to make you ever of that Israeli
federal record and monitored by the IRS
headquarter whatever you speak and
comment it must be closed and harness a
spider because this recording will be
surface and inside also courthouse and
it will come in your favor or against
you so you have to very carefully about
your son yes of course I mean you and
Dad once I've done my part I will give
you enough time to speak and write the
cushion if you have any number one the
aisle respond your suspicion of reading
three important laughter IRS cons for
violation of Internal Revenue Service
case console violation of internal J
Friedel intake country providing
misleading information and now wants to
show you monkey you who is taking care
of your taxes you done by yourself well
I had normally Poland Springs does it
but then it it lino Lacroix
got involved and before I know it I'm up
to my eyeballs and Seltzer you know what
I mean
it's I'm trying to explain it um when I
do the taxes I'm the king of big Seltzer
okay so we get a lot of money from
sir companies and when I filed the tax
return I thought I did everything
correctly I thought I disclosed
everything you know is this something
you can help me with have you dealt with
this before well I mean yes I have it's
embarrassing but I have yes yes I have
I'm sorry is there anybody upset under
the law sorry what was that
no no no how you wanna resolve it inside
of the courthouse or how do we resolve
it outside of the courthouse
sir which one you well I think outside
of the courthouse it sounds better
I can't really get through you're in
charge
the over the line I'm going to connect
your life you're gonna punish me
no Kara died
Thank You officer with a badge ID I are
201 3/8 and I believe I'm speaking with
you sir okay right this is seltzer
kolinsky seltzer kolinsky also known as
David Pakman yes please no courthouse
yes 5000 to 69 you know I have it in
Seltzer futures is that something you
would accept no okay
what would you accept it's not about you
know it's of course it's it's about me I
guess yeah yeah so what options do we
have
okay
and he was not pleased with me he he
apparently much brighter than Jenny
Harper who didn't seem to realize the
entire thing was a joke